je vois partir avec ma femme à l'abri
et donc le tout est pensé pour c'était
son dernier combat bernard tapie nous a
quitté hier matin soixante dix huit ans
depuis quatre ans elle se battait contre
un double cancer un combat acharné
bernard papier est décédé bernard tapie
et vous le savez est décédé à l'âge de
78 ans dirigeant d'entreprise hommes
politiques mais aussi animateur télé
mêmes chanteurs
pour la paix l'homme aux mille vies
celui qui vit à 100 à l'heure passionnés
et surtout engagé dans toutes les
batailles qu'il menait
sa disparition a suscité l'émoi que ce
soit dans le milieu politique du show
biz ou sportifs il n'était pas là pour
être là et il est là pour pour réussir
et gagner le sport et plus précisément
le football à qui il a consacré une
grande partie de sa vie des supporters
marseillais ont tenu à rendre hommage à
leur ancien président
sèye sa ville de coeur là où les
obsèques de bernard tapie auront lieu
vendredi pour un dernier au revoir
joël mercier jean louis borloo dalida
merci un honneur vraiment que tu sois
avec nous ce soir ami de bernard tapie
merci philippe hersen toi qui l'a mis en
scène un était déjà venu vous voir
d'ailleurs quelques sa merci philippe
merci d'être là merci jacques vendroux
j'ai un grand journaliste sportif voilà
dos france et ses amis de bernard
également merci jacques d'être là
jacques séguéla merci d'être là aussi
aux anges actu nous en parlait la
semaine dernière tant parlé sur le
plateau de pascal praud la semaine
dernière tu parlais de bernard c'est
vrai là ils nous écoutent les gens quand
même ne meurt pas ils deviennent
simplement invisible est plus présent
encore que quand il était à côté il est
las d'écouter intérêt à pas dire du mal
des missiles vendée sens il va mettre
une jamais jamais et nadia et comment je
lui ai dit tu mettras la seconde ah bah
oui merci d'être là vous êtes ministre
délégué la ville est ce que c'est vrai
que c'était le poste qu'occupe et
bernard tapie dit ministre de la ville
et boch est-ce que vous avez déjà de
changer avec lui oui j'ai échangé avec
l'iss a été l'une des premières
personnes que j'ai rencontrées juste
après ma nomination c'est fou j'ai
échangé avec lui il ya une dizaine de
jours avant qu'il nous quitte et voilà
on est plein d view il vous disait quoi
et vous donner des conseils sur la wii
wii ah oui et puis j'étais très très
attentive à ce qu'il disait être est
preneuse aussi de ce que pour moi
c'était une sommité bernard tapie
c'était l'idole des jeunes des quartiers
j'étais moi-même enfants des quartiers
tout comme vous savez elle se rend
l'était et donc c'est quelqu'un de très
inspirante son parcours inspirant et
donc voilà je prenais avec beaucoup
d'humilité tous les conseils pour les
touts les échanges aussi qu'on peut
avoir aujourd'hui autour de notre
jeunesse de notre pays actuels et
c'était un grand homme ouais alors jean
louis borloo merci d'être là comme je
vous le dis vous êtes rencontrés comment
avec avec bernard
écoutez il ya 44 ans ah ouais
c'est un jeune avocat et il avait voulu
reprendre un truc à lyon serait pas
marcher plus jeune dit non je vous la
donne pas mais il ya un petit gars
parilla qui pourrait vous avez donc il
est de tout simplement il rentrait dans
le bureau et tout d'un coup j'ai vu de
lumière de chaleur une espèce de
drôlerie d'intelligence des des seuils
absolument extraordinaire et on sait
jamais quitter sauf il ya deux jours
je n'ai jamais quitté
vous l'aviez tout le temps quel fan tout
le temps vous avez tenant il ya des
périodes comme comme dans la vraie vie
tu as eu de tout le vois tous les jour
là les trois derniers mois évidemment
mais
chacun a lu était marseille et moi on
s'y est mis et c'est alors ne s'est
jamais quitté vous parlez de marseille
c'est vrai qu'on l'a dit depuis qu'on
l'a appris le décès de bernard beaucoup
de personnes ont réagi on va vous
montrer l'hommage que les supporters
marseillais ont rendu à celui qu'ils
appelaient tous le boss regarde très tôt
ce matin
les marseillais ont appris la nouvelle
et sont venus déposer des fleurs ou
écrire des messages sur cette photo du
boss comme il aimait le qualifier de 25
ans que je vis derrière le stade batal
mandat on a beaucoup de peine des
marseillais rejoint quelques heures plus
tard par des associations de supporters
gerbe de fleurs à la main par le maire
de la ville en tout près de 600
personnes venues saluer la mémoire du
président qui leur a offert la plus
prestigieuse des coupes d'europe en 1993
en est le seul à ne pas avoir gagné donc
c'est un portable borno on est à jamais
les premiers un hommage mais aussi une
requête que le stade soit rebaptisé le
bernard tapie vélodrome
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des hauts
mal partout sérique manger même été
étonné j'avais un tweet de jean-marie le
pen ça m'a vraiment étonné hier qui
twitte pas ce qu'on voit là on se
rappelle tous de leurs vraiment de leur
combat vraiment respectons que l'on dit
appel c'est un combat parce que je me
rappelle ben wallace mm paul amar à
l'époque
les gants de boxe et c'est vrai que
quand j'ai vu twitté gêné j'ai fait ça
vous a étonné dans le non pas du tout
non ça m'a pas étonné mais moi je suis
venu là parce que vous faites cet
hommage ouais mais avant j'ai appelé se
fit tapie a très bien et la famille très
bien parce que elle a eu de la peine que
je sais que je sais et la famille et
sophie parce que c'est des gens qui ont
un coeur comme ça je sais il n'y a pas
le début d'une rancune et voilà je serai
du matin leur accord ce que je voulais
vous dire vous des ressorts remercier
pour cet hommage à bernard merci jean
luc ça me fait très plaisir parce que
j'ai eu vous savez je suis très proche
de stéphane tapis c'est vrai qu'on a on
a démarré ensemble aller c'est lui qui
m'avait pris je me rappelle là encore on
en a encore parlé ce matin parce que je
les connais avec lui pour les cellules
changer les idées je lui ai dit si tu
veux je vais faire des photocopies parce
qu'en fait on était ensemble vous êtes
toujours des photocopies tous les deux
et il m'a dit tu sais on est comme deux
frères deux frères ça peut s'engueuler
mais ça sème toujours encore plus et
c'est vrai que la famille tapie
eric les aime son fils est aussi elle le
sait et c'est vrai que moi aussi ça m'a
fait beaucoup de peine parce que voilà
chez je la considère tellement comme la
famille que voilà et c'est vrai que je
suis content que tu me dises de
jean-louis parce que mercy ce raid mais
ça clarifie et un bouquet de fleurs ne
fait jamais de mal alors je vais voir ce
que je peux faire
merci oui parce que c'est hyper abordant
moment ils s'embrassent bien sûr
stéphane et laurent que je connais pas
mes qualités je trouve extraordinaire
hier laurent tapie quand il a appelé
c'est nous j'ai trouvé qu'il était
incroyable ça a été incroyable ça c'est
en intervention on va l'avoir regardée
j'aimerais qu'un une fois pour toutes
maintenant qu'il est mort on comprenne
que les emplois qui ont été supprimés
c'était des emplois perdus est ce qu'un
jour après 28 ans vous allez comprendre
ça
les entreprises qui achetaient était
morte que quand il prenait une boîte et
qui avait mille personnes
si on enlevait 300 s'était pas 300 qui
était supprimé 1700 qui était sauvé il
en a sauvé des milliers d emplois c'est
ça que n'avait jamais pu comprendre
quand a surgi un veau coupe une jambe on
va pas s'attarder sur la jambe qui est
coupée et boussens la vie c'est ça qu'il
faut vous compreniez une fois pour toute
et j'espère qu'enfin vous allez arrêter
de débiter ses conneries après 28 ans
ghoul 7 et commencez par vérifier les
faits que vous donnez à l'antenne ça
vous changera ça j'ai trouvé ça
magnifique vraiment c'est je trouvais ça
énorme franchement jacques ça génial
mais génial un mot génial parce qu'ils
sont roms laurent il a pris toutes les
qualités du père ne pas les défauts
mais c'est vrai parce qu'il fait là moi
je entendu ce matin c'était incroyable
mais est ce qu on le sent vraiment qu'il
avait besoin de le dire maintenant il
s'est dit je vais je vais envie de dire
les choses mais trop c'est trop voilà ça
me suffit c'est c'est ce qu'en réalité
il rachetait pas des boîtes en réalité
des gens venaient dans une désespérance
ça déboite partait complètement en
vrille et et et ensemble ils essayaient
la redresser en y apportant une énergie
force à leur téléphone ça marche mal
bien sûr mais c'est ça qu'il faut quand
il faut comprendre que c'était pas un
homme d'argent bernard c'est un homme de
passion sterling 2 tchad et
d'entreprises c'était comme la
championne se lit comme la
transatlantique comme la musique comme
le théâtre comme le cinéma c'était
d'abord un pas et il faut bien
comprendre que bernard tapie il avait
tous les talents du monde là il était
bon mais il ya un problème c'est que ces
cocos qui disent ça maintenant qu'il
faut savoir se faire pardonner et ce qui
faisait qu'avec ses talents il
réussissait quand même incroyablement
faut bien compte qu'elle est le moteur
de sa le moteur c'est sa générosité je
suis sa chaleur c'est la capacité
embarquée les gens parce que c'est pas
lui qui paiera les sur le vélo ces îlots
seleman c'est pas lui qui paraît
vraiment le faussaire pour la transat
c'est pas lui qui avait chauffé les
crampons c'est pas lui qui avait
organisé l'ensemble du terrain c'est pas
lui sauf que à un moment donné est un
homme qui dit à dos d'homme ou à dubaï
on y va on y va on va faire un truc qui
nous dépasse et c'est cette passion 7
est vrai nom l'entreprise intègre en
politique c'est pas la politique il
avait envie de s'occuper des gens comme
il s'en occuper dans les quartiers comme
il s'en occuper tapissez celle inverse
de la caricature que les petits fachos
cela n avait ni sa gueule et son talent
ni sa réussite etc y avait une jalousie
énorme et considère à l'égard de bernard
si c'est quelque chose qui est profonde
et donc que ça sorte la part le rend
bien qu'il vient de perdre j'ai vu ça je
la loue air franchement hier quand j'ai
vu ça lors on je me suis dit aussi il a
il a vidé son sac et l'on pouvait plus
moi je voyais tout les voilà tous les
gens qui ne lâchait pas bernard tapie ça
fait des années qu'on ne le lâche pas
franchement c'est insupportable je
comprends qu'un moment ils craquent
aussi il ya une jalousie mme c'est on
entend du tout sûr je trouve que c'est
sourire même quand il était malade
philippe
la justice oui de la part même des
médias cell on avait l'impression qu'il
kid c'était la voiture baer qui disait
écouter voilà j'ai essayé de faire
beaucoup de bien énormément de bien dans
ma vie même s'il ya plein de gens qui
ont dit le contraire c'est c'est ça
complètement compétition mais il faut
savoir moi je me souviens moi je me
souviens que j'avais d'excellents
rapports avec bernard et m'est arrivé
souvent de l'interviewer sur le football
et cgt j'étais moi aussi jalouse est
parce qu on disait oui mais t'es pas
objectifs et cetera tapis tes copains
avec tapis jg copains et tapis parce que
c'est un mec bien simplement je parle
sous le contrôle de jacques séguéla
comment il récupère l'olympique de
marseille mais c'est un dîner chez
jacques séguéla edmonde charles-roux
jacques séguéla bernard tapie est
aujourd'hui pas à chaque fois il ya un
mauvais coup il
[Musique]
dit à bernard bernard avec tout ce que
vous avez dans les airs il voulait pas
racheter l'olympique de marseille fin si
c'est jean louis et je vais en parler à
gaston et cette phrase marrante que tu
nous raconter mais qui c'est gaston et
les roses et blanches et rouges et simon
marion ces cas seront offerts sur le
maire de marseille devant l'olympique de
marseille si vous êtes d'accord pour un
franc symbolique il quitte le domicile
j'invente rien de jacques séguéla ils
vont à pied au ministère de l'intérieur
créé demande charles euros
bernard tapie et il se retrouve en un
quart d'heure dans le bureau du ministre
de l'intérieur et des jeux tapis oui
bonjour et qui à l'époque bien gaston
defferre
s'est pendu l'olympique de marseille
pour en mai un franc symbolique il
aurait la meilleure équipe d'europe ah
mais là je pars encore je veux pas mais
j'avais eu mon ami gilles verdez
marseille et avec l'as saint-etienne
donc il a pris référencer les vrais
verts de saint-etienne l'arc élèves
avant et ben saint-etienne était un
exemple pour lui il a voulu faire pas un
copier coller mais de marseille il ya
deux clubs qui sont très populaires en
france et encore maintenant l'as
saint-etienne 1re est populaire et
l'olympique de marseille tous les autres
c'est des clubs respecter ces des clubs
qui intéresse les supporters mais ils
ont dans tous les clubs dans toute la
france il ya des clubs il ya des clubs
les supporters de l'om les supporters de
l'asm et c'est de saint-etienne dans
toute la france et des clubs de
l'olympique de marseille et c'est grâce
à bernard bien sûr quand vous voyez mais
partout dans l'est après le décès de
bernard dimanche matin tous les clubs de
france tous les clubs de fond si tu le
sais jean louis du plus haut le milan ac
la juge le bayern de munich ont rendu
hommage et tous les petits gars est de
division d'honneur ils ont rendu hommage
à bernard beffy alors juste vous avez
tous la chance de l'avoir connu l'avez
vous l'avais déjà rencontré vous nadir
ah oui en vrai vous l'avez rencontré
bien c'est ce que moi voilà j'ai un truc
c'est qu'il y avait deux rêves je
voulais rencontrer johnny et je l'avais
rencontrée lors d'une émission et
bernard tapie et bernard tapie en fait
je tourne je crois que je je le voyais
très souvent mais je ne lis jamais vu en
fait j'ai eu avec lui une relation
contre mal et faire lire non mais j'ai
eu une relation téléphonique avec lui en
fait on s'appelait et à chaque fois
qu'il avait un truc qui m'a appelée une
des ananas et tapis quinta vue l'album
de sophie qu est ce qu en pense shiva et
j'aime bien ça y est c'est vrai que je
n'ai jamais rencontré et plein de fois
j'ai stéphane magnier un jour tu verras
je t'emmènerai voilà voir mon père et
c'est vrai que ça restera un grand
regret parce que c'était vraiment
quelqu'un que j'aimais et et non non
vous vous l'avez rencontrée à les
rencontrer il est venu dans mon bureau
on n'a pas assez plu depuis deux heures
et en fait c'était très drôle parce que
j'ai l'impression de l'avoir toujours
connu bernard ainsi moi j'avais 12 ans
quand les l'été ministre et c'est la
personne politique avec françois
mitterrand qui m'ont marqué c'est à dire
que wade dès l'âge de 12 ans et puis
ensuite il est président de ce club il
nous fait découvrir l'om moi
banlieusardes parisiennes
il nous fait découvrir l'om et nous fait
aimer l'om qui n'est pas l'équipe de
france mais qui est l'équipe de la
france et qui nous rend fiers d'être des
quartiers d'être des quartiers nord de
marseille et il nous a fait découvrir
cette ville qu'il aimait tant et la
réussit à nous à nous transmettre cet
amour par l'amour qu'ils avaient du
football donc jacques oui moi j'ai eu la
même chose quelques semaines après ce
fameux dîner il faut qu'il connaisse
jouanno sports cellule donc je te prends
demain chez toi à 18h soit prêt
à 18 heures il arrive à faire en ferrari
on part à 250 à l'heure dans paris je
n'arriverai jamais pour lui lit port on
arrive à l'héliport il prend le lit
kopter il lui même dit d'eux qu'ils
pilotent lui même nom il a réglé et la
manière et c'est bien cela mène
l'hélicoptère
à côté où il y avait un aérodrome à peu
près à 30 km de paris il ya un jet à
dire le pilote
lui même tu l'as vu faire fixant le jet
il en avait la rixe marseille avait une
autre ferrari qui l'attendait en
affaires on arrive je te jure que ses
rivaux sa hausse a dit il était dans
tout ce truc nul comme ça se voit des
planches il tapait il fallut l'échangé
des planches après chaque match et
tactiquement il buvait 3 litres d'eau
par par match et évidemment à la mi
temps il ya un point contre marc contre
marseille didier deschamps ouais laisse
moi faire
était mené 1 0 mais je non marseille
était père était malade tu m'a mené 1 0
est d'accord et 20 buts 0 contre
marseille il y avait un jury de son
vestiaire non non mais mars marseille
avait zéro oui hello tout en
laissant au vestiaire il a eu tout le
bon sens aurait cédé 1 il remonte et ça
a été de 1 pour marseille vous savez
pourquoi pas deux heures du maintien on
reprend le jet parce qu il
[Applaudissements]
tu vas y arrêter ce tte dormir dehors de
chez lui il a eu besoin de dormir dans
son lit lundi soit dans la
réalité
50 ans de grand amour le plus important
ses garde a toujours été sa femme ses
deux amis mais on est arrivé à 4 heures
du matin à paris bon allez c'est une
journée une semaine moi et mes bras
quand on parle avec autant de passion de
bernard mais c'est vrai que je vois je
sais c'est ça qui voit cette passion
qu'on parle tous parce que bernard tapie
ça va encore faire ricaner certaines
personnes des donneurs de leçons
évidemment comme toujours il y en a
beaucoup et un homme il veut te le dire
je vais te dire il fait partie du
patrimoine de la france c'est à dire
qu'il a fait gagner la france via
l'olympique de marseille comme yannick
noah comme alain prost comme michel
platini ces gens là ont fait du bernard
hinault ils ont fait gagner la france à
leur niveau et bernard fait partie de
ces gens qui font partie du patrimoine
d'avoir redonné du bonheur à la france
qu'elle a besoin de deux gagné dans les
années 70-80 etc c'est pour ça qu'il est
hyper populaire qui préférait faire ce
qu'il a fait tellement de choses
politiques hommes d'affaires le cyclisme
le foot le temps
qu'est ce qui d'après qu'est-ce qu'il a
préféré jean louis pour toi
embarquée ouais marqué pour marquer sur
une nouvelle parce qu'en fait il n'a
jamais vraiment voulu les choses ça
toujours été des rencontres ç'a toujours
été des rencontres et à main et elle
rencontre il a l'idée qu'on va y est on
va le faire leur autocar lettre au ca
julliard qui était plus fait pour ça sur
ces bateaux de gaulle as tu une idée
complètement idiote franchement et
qu'elle soit la météo il s'est fait
mitrailler en pleine mer 20 le truc le
type et démons mais mais
moi j'ai tellement entendu de conneries
sur lui je veux dire deux trucs trois
trucs magiques connaît l'histoire de la
petite zohra
franco-marocaine donc ma peau qu'il
avait adapté henri clément sert du
poumon il la croiser la chétive avoir
adopté par an à 3
en accord avec les parents il l'a pris
chez lui avec dominique ils s'en sont
occupé jusqu'au départ de la peep
deuxième que vous raconte mieux le vrai
taper parce que tapie c'était un pudique
ça il serait furieux je raconte c'était
un pudique il essaie truc c'était un
fils de deux jours jean tapis ouvrier
communiste mais il aller au catéchisme
et ils apprenaient le violon en même
temps deuxième c'est quand il fait
ambitions keith carr l abstraction
juste parce que je faut savoir ça il a
un énorme cachet à ce moment là elle
vient à la fin d'un des cinq ambitions
il verra marie france brière la
productrice et dit attends avec ce que
j'ai vu là m'ont caché c'est pour la
fondation abbé pierre marie france
brière et je peux pas rater les services
publics les comptes avons pas d'accord
tu te démerdes tu le fais et puis
dernier truc les écoles pour les gamins
là les sept ou huit écoles qu'il a
montée pour
rien du quartier popu vendeurs etc il
les a plié de sa poche personne ne l'a
jamais su le vrai bernard tapie c'est
comme lino ventura avec personnages ces
mecs là ils disent pas c'est vrai truc
jamais ils sont d'une pudeur
invraisemblable c'était un type qui
avait la foi du charbonnier
c'est tout à fait tout à fait étonnant
verna et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont dans
une très belle cérémonie à saint charles
à saint tu tu as raison jean louis moi
j'étais malheureusement à furiani et je
tombais oriani alors est ici le fil
c'est le drame de furiani à bientôt 30
ans et c'est gilles aussi et moi je me
qui était aussi gillard et g et il est
muni de la ville il est président de
l'om le match est annulé à cause des
troncs de la tribune qui tombe et cetera
il s'est occupé des gens les personnes
ne l'a su il s'en est occupé
personnellement il allait voir les gens
blessés à l'hôpital de bastia il allait
voir les gens blessés qui étaient la
salpêtrière où dans des hôpitaux il a
suivi et tu le sais il a suivi la faire
jusqu'au bout et on peut le dire
maintenant jusqu'à être prescription
c'est lui c'est lui je le dis parce que
j'étais directement concernés c'est lui
qui s'est occupé de sauver entre
guillemets les blessés de furiani c'est
lui qui dirigeait les pompiers
une jeune tu peux nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé le cg les bars en fête la
légion il était là et je crois que
bernard tapie peut-être tata il est bien
sûr le 5 mai 1992 quand la tribune et
est tombé c'était une scène des froids
et je me suis retrouvé propulsé où j'ai
marché vers le vestiaire marseillais est
donc à ce moment là je suis tombé à
l'intérieur du vestiaire sur bernard
tapie je saignais je l' ai vu je lui dis
c'est terrible c'est la première fois
que je le voyais et donc il ya eu comme
ça un déclic il a emmené ses joueurs
vers le chaos et il a pris effectivement
les gens par terre mourant grièvement
blessé et avec basile boli et les appris
les mettait dans les ambulances et ce
jour là il est devenu mon héros parce
que et il aurait pu protéger ses joueurs
il aurait pu être en retrait mais non il
s'est impliqué et jamais il n'a voulu le
raconter j'aimerais me disait toujours
mais quand des gens critiquent est
appelée dîme et toi t'as vu raconte si
tu veux mais moi je veux pas aisée mais
pourquoi vous racontez pas je vous ai vu
vous avez sauvé des dizaines de
personnes les avait mises dans les
ambulances je veux pas raconter je veux
passer ces voix là et en fait c'était ça
il est tellement public qui voulait pas
se mettre en avant et ce jour là moi je
je je reste admiratif de ce qu'il a fait
et se sauver des villes à lille à l'été
à son honneur il est rentré à paris il
rentre à paris il a fait il ya certes
une personne qui sont restés à bastia
parce qu'il n'était pas transportable
enfants vraiment refaire le film etc
mais quand il rentre à paris il va la
salpêtrière il va voir gérard saillant
que tu connais qui a soigné la plupart
d'entre nous et c est il était il nous
suivait tu compenses il nous suivait
c'est-à-dire qu'ils lâchent rien et puis
au moment quand il a vu qu'on allait
imploser et cetera bon après il tape les
quinze jours après ce que tu vas mieux
et cetera c'est pour ça que c'est un mec
je dire moi quand on la taille et
pendant des années j'en étais malade
parce que mais j'écris quand raconter
l'histoire de furiani où d'autres
histoires ce qui est incroyable c'est
que les gens ne nous croyez pas penser
qu'on était aux ordres ils pensaient
qu'on était complètement cédé à même
chez nous la racaille bonne foi ainsi il
osé même pas nous l'a raconté gilles
parce qu'il voulait je sais que bernard
voulait pas tuer voilà il était pas met
en avant jacques j'ai l'impression voilà
et je ne vois je vois si jacques
vendroux on l'a vu chez eux le un des
fils de bernard matin il ya aussi des
gens qui disent franchement on l'a ce
que je dis est alors on l'a pas lâché
quoi bernard c'est ce qu'il a préféré
dans sa vie ouais c'est d'être ministre
ah c'est vrai mais bon vous sur sa forme
et jamais pareil je n'avais pas
l'impression moi je croyais pas moi ya
quinze jours avec ce mini mais qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que tu as préféré dans ta
vie m'a dit s'être ministre mais ça m'a
échappé tout de suite ouais ils m'ont
volé marseille parce que son rêve
c'était devenir maire de martrin et
comme c'était le chouchou de françois
mitterrand sur un caddie du conseil des
ministres vous êtes nuls en
communication regardez tapie est faite
comme tapie elle avait cité mis tous les
ans une seule réunion
s'est battu toute sa vie pour essayer de
faire ce qu'il est mais c'est à dire la
politique qu'il a tué le jour où il a
décidé de quitter adidas pour la
politique je l'avais dit d'ailleurs sa
famille l'avait dit sophie ma femme lui
avait dit m rentre pas chez des piranhas
ils vont te dévorer
tu penses tu prends passé c'est fou ce
que vous dites là chaque parce qu'on
sent tellement fort mais un art tapis
alors voilà je me dis franchement et
quand vous dites ils ne rentrent pas
chez les perdants on se dit bernard
tapie va s'en sortir que son dos le
regret de sa vie lorsqu'il a tout réussi
le regrette sa vie et c'est là vine
accessoires sais pas ce que je ferai de
marseille j'aurais fait de marseille la
grande capitale du monde capitale du
sport la plus totale du jeu capitale du
bonheur et actuel du solaire
prescription maintenant mais je vous
raconter une anecdote quelques secondes
j'ai des amis à moi qui avais un hôtel à
barcelonnette le chose qu'avait et
l'olympique de marseille allait
régulièrement faire des stages en hiver
pour faire du ski de fond et c'est à
l'olympique de marseille domergue jreige
que tel c'est toute la bande moser
carlos mozer ils allaient dans cet hôtel
et un jour et hôtels je fais pas les
nommer parce qu'il faut être un peu
pudique avait des problèmes financiers
le patron est et war bernard unis est ce
que tu peux m'aider
oui il a aidé personne ne l'a su les
gens rembourser peut-être deux ou trois
ans après mais il avait un coeur énorme
et la sauver cet hôtel alors que c'était
pas du tout son hôtel il à sauver des
emplois maintenant il faut se lâcher
maintenant faut dire la vérité c'est
celle des deux jours du procès c'était
je le dis une nouvelle fois c'était un
mec enfin je parle sous le contrôle de
jean louis c'était un mec bien c'était
un mec réglo c'était un mec honnête tout
le monde dit oui ou à la patati patata
on raconte beaucoup de caudry beaucoup
de bêtises ont été racontées même sur un
certain nombre de choses notamment dans
le football de mauls et vécu directement
avec bernard avec fournet fayard avec
platini etc il ya un millième de vérité
alors évidemment quand il y avait un
match entre le paris saint-germain et
l'om bon il salue mais avec denise et
cetera mais c'était pas méchant
mettez la pression sur l'armée tentant à
c'est toi qui va arbitrer aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'il va les dons il y avait
cru etc c'était un jeu de rôle mais
c'était marrant n'y a jamais eu de
méchanceté et mais on a raconté
tellement de conneries qu'ils avaient
des matches qui avait été clair qui
expirera c'est faux je dis que tu es
d'accord avec marc était jaloux et parce
que tout le monde croyait que c'était le
fruit qui l'intéressait mais pas du tout
maintenant ce n'est pas du tout une
machine à fric tapie c'était une machine
à idées à gagner de la chine est le
coeur et ce qu'ils voulaient de l'argent
pour créer des choses pour faire des
choses pour aider les gens pour essayer
d'améliorer la vie des français parce
que faut pas oublier que finalement ce
cas qui était le moteur de tapis pendant
toute sa vie c'est d'aimer les français
et d'être aimés à son tour alors les
français et on peut pas être aimé par
les gens si on ne les aime pas soi même
et toute sa vie s'est battu pour ça
c'est pour ça qu'il aurait voulu être
ministre je pense jamais président pense
qu'un jour il m'a dit mais enfin tu as
rêvé d'être président il m'a dit non je
n'avais pas la pointure un voile
humilité qui tout réussit j'en avais pas
la pointure un jour il m'a invité à
manger un poulet frites chez lui rue des
saints pères il me dit moi franchement
village
et donc et donc
dix mois la vérité est ce que je fais
partie des des grands présidents du foot
j'y mets par bernard attend il ya henri
germain fameux président du stade de
reims grand président roger rocher louis
nicollin francis borelli jean louis
campora suis dit là il fait partie des
grands perdants du football français il
a révolutionné le football jean-louis le
sait il était président de valenciennes
pendant des années le football avant
l'arrivée de bernard ntma on se lâche et
les penno crise il était marron diagne
et plus on s'emmerdait amassés sur
thématiquement éliminé en ligue des
champions et servira il a convaincu
platini de reprendre l'équipe de france
il a deux regrets
maradona il le voulait à marseille et
quand il a vu qu'il pouvait pas maradona
pour y avait
[Musique]
un petit peu dangereux de le faire
et d'en vivre génération france marine
c'est ça alors que
vous l'avez tous eu au téléphone
peut-être dernièrement que c'est quoi la
le dernier mot qui vous a dit jacques le
cclat sionisés quelques mois sacré
c'était la semaine dernière il ya une
dizaine de jours je lui ai dit écoute
maintenant qui va nous quitter tu veux
tu vas retrouver françois mitterrand la
aux
quels il faut vraiment que tu vas les
vidéos avaient dit oui qu'est les
derniers mots que le premier mot qui va
lui dire ça a fusé il a dit hey force de
l'esprit est en train de mourir le corps
foutez le camp l'esprit tourné à 100
kilomètres à l'heure j'ai dit après et
pour qui tu vas voter il a réfléchi
bernard et réfléchie rarement parce que
tout est dans sa tête déjà programmée et
chaque fois que ça fuse tarif
généralement il m'a dit écoute il y en a
qu'un qui a la stature et qui a le
courage et qui a la force de pouvoir
changer la france c'est notre président
c'est manuel macron et grâce à bernard
il connaissait par coeur je parle aussi
sur le contrôle de villes il connaissait
par coeur la composition le président
mac on connaît par coeur la composition
de l'équipe de l'om finaliste et qui
gagne 1,93 dans les buts fabien barthez
et terra l'histoire barthez elle est
extraordinaire il va jouer à toulouse
avec l'om on y voit barthez qui
gardienne toulouse le jeune gardien de
20 ans fait une session il dit au
président de toulouse à l'époque lui dit
mais ton gardien c'est ce mec là si on
s'en occupe pas comme il faut ce type là
va devenir le meilleur gardien de but du
monde le président aurait pu remonter
coûte moi je te dis le fabien barthez
qui joue à toulouse va devenir le
meilleur gardien de but du monde alors
ça veut dire quoi je te l'achète
mais il a acheté une poignée de main
ouais il a fait la carrière à marseille
et après on avait battu alain buffard je
veux dire il l'a fait il a été le
meilleur quart des deux buts du monde
sait que c'est quoi le dernier mot vous
avez dire vous l'avez eu quand on
connais moi j'ai dit aussi il ya une
dizaine de jours il était très fatigué
et c'est vrai que c'est un homme qui
adorait la politique en tout cas c'est
ce que j'ai ressenti
donc pendant tous nos échanges et il
était assez assez nombreux et donc il
était sincère bernard tapie dans tout ce
qu'il fait dans tout ce qu'il
entreprenait la question de la
générosité c'était un homme généreux
dans tout ce qu'il faisait il donnait
sans compter c'est peut-être ça aussi
qui faisait qu'il nous atteignait nous
gêne dans nos quartiers où la vie était
difficile où il nous disait vous avez
cette capacité d'entreprendre allez-y
son dernier est un exemple enfin le
dernier échange qu'on a eues il était
sincère dans ses combats politiques dans
le combat contre les que vous avez quoi
il m'a dit tu sais une ministre en
exercice a droit d'être en colère et
donc tu as tu vois des choses et tu es
en colère tu as droit de le dire et est
donc aujourd'hui je dis voilà
effectivement je suis en colère de ce
qui se passe des débats qui dérive
aujourd'hui
sur une certaine idée de la politique
qu'il a toujours combattu et qu'il avait
raison de combattre et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on poursuive tous ensemble ce
combat contre eux n'ont pas encore parlé
parce que c'est vrai que tous les jours
on voit ce qui se passe un mois là il ya
des déclarations gens parlent encore
tout à l'heure qu'on n'aurait pas vu
mais il était sa milice 15 ans et sept
îles et il est fou de sa fille c'est
quoi le dernier dans la phrase que vous
lui avez dit vous voyez quoi tuer
bernard ya une quinzaine de jours mais
était vraiment fatigué elle avait
vraiment bas c'était même ça sentait
bien ce qui est très bizarre c'est
paradoxal par rapport à quelques mois
encore au printemps dernier en il arrive
dans la gnac il vous faut absolument que
tu ne trouves une pièce de théâtre faut
absolument contraire je trouve ta vie
d'ailleurs la nation mais c'est pas
possible c'est toujours ça les projets
étaient toujours il veut les jouer de
jean valjean dans les voiles art et
misérable allez encore un an
il faut que tu appelles tout michel
c'est impensable la veille le [ __ ] je
suis encore qu'il ya quelques mois c est
et vous jean-louis ce que je vous ai vu
sur une autre antenne série que c'était
très fort ce que vous avez dit non -
c'est ce vendredi
il y avait dominique celui
ils étaient tous paniqué parce qu'elle
n'était pas là elle était allée chez le
culte l'oculiste une demi-heure sont
laissés lunettes
pas 2 min que c'est pas possible et il y
avait sophie qui va recevoir un bouquet
de fleurs y avait laurent il y avait
déjà beaucoup plus arriver nathalie et
il est dès lors on l'a compris il faut
aller chercher les chiens c'est un homme
qui adorait les animaux il en a pris de
la spa d absolument incalculables et
simplement il m'appelait sa main chaude
là comme ça et puis ceux des caressé par
dominique et le petit commis sur la
d'élèves et fait un clin d'oeil comme ça
merci merci jean louis s'est alors c'est
extraordinaire parce que dominique hier
m'a montré les photos qu'elle a fait
justement de ces chiens sera à ce moment
là et on voit cet anime l'énorme chien
tu sais
ce chien s'était couché sur bernard il
avait ce sac tu vois qu'ils étaient là
et la main de bernard dans sa patte
ouais incroyable et le chien c'était moi
dans les journaux on va dire pour ce
très fort à la famille voit la seule
fille qui embrasse fort elle sait que je
laime à stéphane alors on à dominique à
toute la famille tapie et surtout à
bernard surtout à bernard qu'on aimait
tout ce qu'on admirait